Ben we're having a date this is not hump
your pillow time you've probably seen
the show worth it where's Stephen Adam
and Andrew compare three different meals
at three drastically different spice
points but for me in my life Arielle
question isn't so much where should we
go out its should we even go out so
today we're gonna compare a home-cooked
meal to one that you can get at a fancy
restaurant and then we're gonna see
which one made a better taste it's
obviously good for you tonight at work
just the whole what's the word I'm
thinking of I had gentry the identity of
it we love this pageantry of it right
now
it's raining and I'm excited about maybe
putting on our PJs there are a lot of
advantages to stay in it but first we
gotta go grocery shopping what should we
make like a salmon veggie grab yeah
that's three simple
so tiny we have in the bag - apparently
that doesn't show I'm gonna get cookin
for me today is super simple it's just
potatoes green beans and salmon and I
looked up a recipe for like a soy ginger
garlic honey glaze what didn't I cook
this on you just put it on the pan
uh-huh
[Music]
now it's glaze time
[Music]
they got bad potatoes Oh bean well beam
you got a potato let's make some space
for our salmon yeah very nice glass sexy
glazed green beans now we just put it
back in there we go nice
[Music]
mmm okay that glaze is really popping
it's like a tap dancing on your tongue
Oh like dignity but then it's almost
like overpowering oh the potatoes are
the best oh yeah this meal is like super
basic it's really very delicious you've
been me we're having a date this is not
hump your pillar times speed this is day
time oh my god ooh tell me that is if
you like the soy and the honey in the
glaze it's kind of caramelized potatoes
I know I hear I'm sitting at home in our
comfy pants I feel like I can absolutely
care bye it's time to go to the fancy
restaurant Oh before we do I think we
got to change okay so we just have an
awesome meal and now we're going out to
a fancy restaurant iron so excited so
we'll see how a night out compares to
the night in even though it's daytime
where we got we're going to Providence
LA one of the premiere seafood
restaurants in Los Angeles we're gonna
talk to the owner the only owner and
head chef ownership owner chef he's more
of a player coach tell us about the
restaurant what are we gonna be doing
today we are going to be cooking a
quenelle River coho salmon today with
honey nut squash and fall that you're
looking for a fish that's a little bit
fatty skin should be nice and green and
shiny see the oil is like really hot
smoking hot and then we'll just
carefully place the fillets into the pan
we want to get like a little bit of
color so it has like a nice light golden
sort of appearance you don't need very
much fat at all it helps to preserve a
true flavor of the fish and then we're
just gonna let it rest for like three or
four minutes so in the meantime we have
our honey nut squash that's stuffed with
all those vegetables it's like a 72 hour
process we start out with make a very
rich vegetable broth with a little bit
of pancetta in it lots of kombu or
seaweed we cook that broth one day with
all sorts of vegetables and then we take
it off the fire and cool it with the
vegetables in their second day we strain
it and then we repeat the process again
new kombu new Concetta we strain it out
and those are the vegetables and we make
the stuffing with and we reduce down
that bra and we glaze the squash with
that this is a puree of that state wok
we took the skin off the salmon and we
made these little crisps and then we
also use it as a base for the sauce that
we prepare for the salmon which is a
black couple sites it's a very involved
preparation but when you look at the
dish it looks deceptively simple oh my
goodness I'm sorry fish looks awesome
you ready so luxurious it's like it's
like velvety oh gosh you're incredible I
usually don't like squash but this is
just so deep I'm complex let's try some
I think my favorite is probably with
truffle sauce mm-hmm like it coats your
mouth you can tell it's a really high
quality fish for those who's gonna eat
via the crispy salmon with crispy salmon
skin I'll try it I mean we could try to
make this at home but I highly doubt
it's gonna come out like that so good
like a salty little little cracker snack
oh my gosh Cheers at home we would
normally just drink whatever wine was in
the fridge right typically the second
cheapest Bob of mine or the cheapest
bottle of wine
I mean when do we ever get four hours to
just talk to each other never never
only when we had go out to eat all right
one more right maybe seven more bites oh
yes Wow based on the taste of the dish
as well as the entire ambiance of the
experience which date did you prefer
you know I love our home and I love our
dogs but I feel like the night out was
just so perfect the ambience of the
restaurant and the wine I mean with the
truffle oil and like cook the salmon
just a little bit on both sides and then
let it rest like we leave something out
on the counter being will eat it yeah I
hope the day that I prefer the night out
the restaurant Simon was amazing but in
terms of the overall experience being
able to cook with you and play with the
dog I like that the sauce that we had on
that salmon was so flavorful like sweet
of salty the fact that we can make that
at home was pretty cool I gotta say I
prefer the night in I feel like I forgot
I six hours with you know well thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
night in vs. night out we should go home
and check on being okay
[Music]